nous allons faire aujourd'hui
connaissance avec une toute jeune
entreprise du secteur de
l'agroalimentaire
depuis la mi septembre ont produit ici à
livarot des bronches et à ses tartines
typique de la cuisine italienne
je vous propose de détailler la recette
non pas de la branche et âme mais celle
qui a permis à sophie amer la fondatrice
de lancer sa petite industrie
l'héroïne de cette histoire c'est elle
porte drapeau avec la pizza de la
gastronomie de la péninsule
une histoire qui débute tout simplement
un jour dans la cuisine familiale de
sofia meurt c'est un produit que l'on
faisait chez nous à titre personnel et
puis un jour ça nous a donné l'envi
éventuellement on a envisagé de le faire
de façon beaucoup plus industrielles
après avoir fait le constat qu
effectivement sur le marché européen ça
n'existait pas on s'est lancé sur ce
marché convaincu donc d'avoir trouvé la
bonne idée surfant sur la mode du
snacking quelques mois encore pour
peaufiner sa recette est lancé l'étape
suivante elle aussi essentielle choisir
le lieu où implanter la production en
prospectant dans le pays d'auge sophie
croiser l'équipe de la communauté de
communes de livarot ici on ne manque pas
de place dans la zone d'activités et les
élus semblent tout disposé à s'investir
il faut un petit peu plus de tous un
petit peu plus de disponibilité des
cellules aller à la recherche des
subventions
travailler avec les entreprises
l'administration pour pour ne pas que
les délais s'allongent d'aussi bouclée
en un temps record moins d'un an entre
les premiers contacts et la remise des
clés du bâtiment flambant neuf 2800 m² 3
millions et demi d'euros financés par la
collectivité est loué à l'entreprise un
poids de moins pour la jeune pousse
concentrer désormais sur le lancement de
l'activité
ce que finalement l'entreprise ne
finance pas en direct puisque au final
on affine en sera tout de même
mais ce qu'elle ne finance pas tout de
suite ça permet d'avoir un
investissement sur autre chose sur des
machines sur sur des matières sur
suppression autre chose autre chose
c'est notamment recruté une équipe de 15
personnes
l' agence pour l'emploi de lisieux
apportera son savoir-faire dénicher des
salariés de l'agroalimentaire mais pas
uniquement
ce qui compte avant tout c'est la
motivation des candidats qui suivront
ensuite une formation de cette semaine
on l'apprêté nos je dirais personnes
intéressées à un test un exercice donc
pour connaître plus les aptitudes et le
bon état d'esprit donc des personnes
intéressées que plutôt sur des
compétences vraiment professionnel je
voulais que ces personnes qui faisait
partie de l'équipe de départ on puisse
les emmener avec nous et que ces
personnes puissent grandir en même temps
que la société
c'est le cas de sabrina précédemment
elle travaillait dans l'industrie
automobile
ici elle est animatrice d'équipé ont
grandi en même temps que l'entreprise
qui on voit le produit n'est très
la csmb donc on évoluera en même temps
que l'entreprise
le 20 septembre la production et lancer
à livarot cinq recettes différentes soit
deux villes brouch état par jour
confectionnée sur l'unique ligne de
production et ce avec un début se fie à
mr ne manque pas d'appétit
on prévoit dans les 4 à 5 ans d'avoir
des cinquantaine d'employés et d'avoir
une capacité de production qui soit 4 à
5 fois supérieure à celle que l'on a
aujourd'hui dans les rayons des
supermarchés
le produit plaît et l'exportation sur un
le prochain challenge vendre un jour des
bouches et à médine normandie en italie
serait une véritable consécration
voilà ce que ton à se fier à son équipe
de confirmer au fil du temps le succès
de sa brousse état car la ville des
entreprises rosset n'est pas un long
fleuve tranquille et rien n'est
définitivement gagné à lundi prochain
pour un nouveau c'est normand